elaborate what he means by
doing your best again being doing your
best means doing your best I don't know
why you don't understand English
did you try really to calculate all
these complications all these variations
till the end somehow and this was
possible no I was thinking what to eat
tonight
well Alaska wasn't talking about the
samish variation which was where we were
and here it's quite a typical move
again in the same variation you're not
yep Mr Raman after this
are you considering
no
I mean he got one point you got one in
half and you're sharing right you are
tied for the first place I think I am
half a point behind him yeah well thank
you for putting me in the joint lead but
it's not been the case for a thing